ele está ligado
boa tarde a região metropolitana do rio
de janeiro
as regiões metropolitanas e geraldo
brasil vive uma situação de limbo algo
como se fosse um purgatório das
políticas públicas
a metrópole contemporânea ela solicita
alguns pilares e alguns são fundamentais
está a sustentabilidade ambiental a
questão da mobilidade a questão do
respeito ea valorização da diversidade
ea questão da integração do território
a estrutura federativa brasileira
apesar de dizer videntes avanços pode
constituinte colocou a região
metropolitana numa zona de esquecimento
e nós aqui no rio como todos já viram
longo do dia 18 municípios num total de
estes oito municípios tem 12 milhões de
habitantes num estado que tem 16 milhões
de habitantes a capital tem 6 milhões de
habitantes metade dessa população é o
maior desafio nesse contexto
contemporâneo é como dar conta da
desigualdade das múltiplas formas das
desigualdades como enfrentar de forma
sólida desigualdade e portanto usando a
imagem do teatro como trazer para o
centro do palco
a capacidade de forma coordenada
enfrentarmos e reduzirmos a desigualdade
que evidentemente a nossa história tem
patamares no mínimo indesejáveis e
certamente vergonhosos para fazer isso
dois caminhos são fundamentais
o primeiro é fazer com que a política
social têm uma relação de equivalência
com a polícia económica e social não
seja mais uma dimensão subordinada
subalternas frente à política econômica
essa conversa de guarda para outros é
difícil
o segundo caminho que é o caminho que eu
quero explorar o caminho daqui a gente
precisa promover uma coordenação
significativa das políticas públicas que
dê conta de olhar os territórios e
considerar sujeito concretos famílias
concretas neste território concretos e
essa não é a nossa cultura o sol
eu falo sobre isso a partir de um lugar
que nos últimos 20 muitos anos eu tenho
dedicado à questão pública num sentido
amplo tanto na pesquisa como na gestão
das atividades de pesquisa como
professor da universidade federal
fluminense com o pesquisador do
instituto de pesquisa econômica aplicada
trabalhando durante anos sobre a questão
desigualdades e depois um mergulho na
gestão pública
eu não vou trazer aqui como foi colocada
no sã bado segmento básico casos
específicos mas a partir dessa
plataforma
mas o governo federal foi secretário
executivo do ministério desenvolvimento
social e à época tive a felicidade de
poder coordenar o desenho a implantação
do bolsa família que obviamente
trabalhava com renda educação e saúde
depois do ministério da educação sendo
secretário de educação construindo uma
agenda nova uma nova secretaria a seca
de educação continuada alfabetização e
diversidade que trazia a questão das
desigualdades da diversidade para o
centro da agenda da educação tratando a
educação indígena educação quilombola
educação rural educação nas prisões
educação ambiental educação de jovens e
adultos todos os temas associados à
desigualdade racial a orientação sexual
tudo que está em geral escondido debaixo
do tapete que as pessoas não trabalhava
organizando isso dentro do magistrado
cassação depois aqui no estado com o
secretário estadual de direitos humanos
e assistência social
trabalhando com a pauta direitos humanos
mas sobretudo caminho da construção do
pp social que é um esforço enorme de
tentativas de condenação no território
na cena social daí o instituto pereira
passos presidido pela paz no rio de
janeiro segundo de urbanismo conduzindo
a política social que seria um caso à
parte do pessoal é um caso de várias
experiências que a gente podia nadar
aqui hoje estou na fundação privada
instituto unibanco trabalhando com cinco
estados
a educação uma parceria público privada
aqui no ensino médio tratar mais ou
menos com um trabalho mais ou menos com
15% da matrícula do ensino regular
brasileiro à experiência
evidentemente com alguns acertos e
muitos erros e permite refletir sobre
essa questão da coordenação de forma a
entender no nosso contexto não no
contexto do android foi colocada
anteriormente no contexto do brasil no
contexto da realidade do rio de janeiro
como é que esta estratégia possível de
olhar pro metrop e produzir inter ações
concretas no território é vital para a
gente dá conta de um modo de fazer que
tem a capacidade de enfrentar
desigualdades que devia ter a funcionar
sondados eu vou ter só seis lotes três
que são único indicador a cni o
indicador simplíssimo a renda domiciliar
por família por pessoa e não o vermelho
a pior situação aí um valor de qualidade
e poder de compra com menos de 500
quinhentos reais per capta eo azul entre
o azul escuro entre 1.500 e 2.000
evoluiu desde maio 18 municípios tudo
vermelho
aqui você chegar em o pão é difícil tudo
vermelho em 91 só rio-niterói separados
ainda continua muito vermelho um
pouquinho laranja 2010 é esse cenário
melhorou evidentemente melhorou nosso
país tem melhorado mas só nesse quesito
de renda que obviamente reducionista - a
questão da desigualdade
a gente vê que há uma desigualdade
enorme entre os municípios que foram
colocados em quarentena para cada
município
a gente vê que cada município dentro
dele tem uma desigualdade enorme
se a gente pegar são gonçalo a renda de
jardim amendoeira que a região mas cobra
em torno de 260 reais per capta o vale
de área que a região mágica tem 1 mil e
trezentos reais per capta nova iguaçu
lagoinha quilômetro 32 têm mais ou menos
300 reais per capita quando ele vai para
o centro nova iguaçu 1.500 rio de
janeiro acari barros filho e costa
barros na verdade são as duas regiões
mais vulneráveis que a gente tem
mas a renda per capita de 400 reais na
lagoa de seis mil oitocentos reais
então tive que a desigualdade entre
territórios e entrou territórios quando
ele desce no interior do território a
gente for a campo grande que a região
mais pobre do rio de janeiro
mas dentro de campo grande tem o sesaram
sesaram é muito pior do que a média de
junho no campo grande e aqui o perdão a
gente olha um território específico isso
aqui é são joão um ovo uma favela
pacificada perto da linha do trem foi
estruturada zona norte
a gente vê a desigualdade à tona a
tonalidade é a mesma o vermelho é o pior
o verde é melhor não tem azul tam e aqui
não é mais venda aqui um conjunto de 17
indicadores nesse conjunto 17
indicadores
a gente vê essa distância aquela região
lá em cima que está vermelha e rosa que
é o quieto
a gente tem aqui cidade do rio de
janeiro zona norte pertíssimo à beira do
trilho do trem
a gente tem esgoto a céu aberto tem
estado de cavalo tem de chão com a
atuação de mais ou menos dois palmos tem
pouco que eu vi com um metro e meio
sendo cassado pelos meninos
a outra região embaixo que é vermelho e
verde estão vendo ali o verde a melhor
região que tem infraestrutura do
favela-bairro no vermelho a gente foi um
casalinho de quase 20 casas sem nenhuma
ventilação casebres com tuberculose em
incidência enorme de doenças é chá foi
enfrentado mas a desigualdade entre o
território é muito forte com a questão
nós temos um desigualdades significativa
a desigualdade entre territórios muito
forte ea desigualdade entre territórios
muito forte agora sobre esse contexto a
gente tem um enorme complexidade de
possibilidades coordenação de programas
sócio diagrama de interações com as três
esferas federal estadual municipal e
três agendas só saúde educação
assistência e vejam que a gente tem o
desafio de coordenar essa aqui
o ministério da saúde tem coordenar a
política de dst/aids certo com a
política de drogas missão em coordenação
com a secretaria estadual e tem
coordenar com a secretaria municipal
agora o ministro da educação tem que
conversar com o ministério da
assistência social para pensar a
política de direita sem postar
o ministério da educação para a
prevenção dentro da escola só aí só
nessa esfera são nove internações
quando se considera as três esferas de
governo e as três áreas a gente tem 27
interações seja pensar que a ida e volta
podiam ser 54 eu só pensava 27
interações se eu botar mais uma área de
saneamento básico falar das duas horas a
2 apresentações atrás se fala de 27 para
42 de botar quarto a quinta geração
mobilidade coisa de 20 de 42 para 60 de
votar a sexta área a ses quiserem
resíduos sólidos
a gente passa para 81 interações 81
interações no território a região
metropolitana que dá por 18 depois fazem
a proteção vejam quantas interações são
necessárias em um ambiente de enorme
complexidade quando está pensando que
temos que olhar não de forma abstrata
território de forma concreta objetivo
territórios com sujeitos reais que têm
sua complexa vida não só a vida da
clarice japeri que foi dito há pouco mas
a vida de várias famílias estruturadas
mais ou menos com múltiplas complexidade
com muitas estruturas com crianças tendo
que tomar conta de outras crianças que
estão criança de 12 anos que tomou
criança de quatro anos com uma mãe que
trabalha 34 horas de distância uma volta
em casa está na assistência social eles
têm toda essa complexidade dessa agenda
agora o que é mais grave é que a
desigualdade entre entre inter é muito
forte a complexidade das interações
gigantesca é e a gente tem desafios
estruturais na construção da realidade
da cultura da política pública
brasileira
quero sair daqui sair muito forte e que
são desafios que não são da mesma
natureza do suíço na universal não é
assim no mundo que a gente tem quatro
características fortes que eu vou ter
que correr por causa do nosso tempo
a fragmentação da política na estrutura
clássica de fragmentação eu tenho regras
diferentes para o mesmo programa eu
tenho um baixíssimo a transparência tem
um jogo de pequenos poderes ea
fragmentação da política pública que
parece a maioria das pessoas
um ato de ineficiência na realidade
brasileira é um ato de eficiência de uma
política orientada pelo clientelismo
o fragmento produz reações
nas relações de clientela está a serviço
de uma velha forma de gestão não é um
erro é um modo eficaz de se fazer uma má
política
mas além da fragmentação
a fragmentação é mais fácil enfrentar
soltam-se chicão
depois da fragmentação eles têm
sobreposição das políticas e na
sobreposição das polícias que a gente
tem várias áreas do governo federal o
governo estadual no governo municipal
pensando com o peso político de conteúdo
semelhante eu tô vendo aqui a maioria do
próximo mês quantidade de programas
sobre os jovens que existe no rio de
janeiro na metrópole na cidade
qual é a política de juventude que
existe com essa quantidade de programas
e quando a gente olha o território
concreto que a gente vê áreas nesse
território com incidência de várias
ações federais estaduais e municipais
daquele programa e literalmente você
atravessar a rua
do outro lado não tem aquele programa
isso é um efeito dessa situação de
sobreposição das políticas
ao mesmo tempo uma um captar da política
pública feita pelas redes sociais para
redes sociais nos espaços vulneráveis
muitas vezes associadas às futuras
cooperativas estruturas religiosas que
acessam e se essa situação meio de
desinformação que na política pública e
faz o quê segmentos específicos dentro
de favelas nas regiões mais pobres
tenham mais acesso a alguns problemas do
que outros segmentos que não têm
ela não se distribui de forma
minimamente imagine o território mas
além da sobreposição nós temos a
terceira característica que é o
isolamento dos setores talvez a mais
difícil de todos
é evidente que cada setor de saneamento
básico mobilidade o tratamento de
resíduos sólidos a educação a saúde
precisa de densidade vetorial e de muito
conteúdo para que nossas políticas sejam
sólidos consistentes e evidentemente
efetivas no entanto a nossa cultura
institucional é de uns 10 lamento de
cada um desses setores em que cada um
não conversa com outro que não troca que
não busca a interação e portanto você
perde a força dessa daquilo que pode ser
transformado concentrar pensa em um
exemplo simples que é uma criança com
desta tensão o congresso visual numa
escola dentro do território argentino
os agentes da saúde da família
dividir aquele território de um
determinado modo que é diferente da
gente é dada assistência social e que
nenhum dos dois conversa com o diretor
você demora quatro anos para descobrir
que aquele não tem déficit de
aprendizagem coletivo por de vida outra
limitação porque nunca no território
real área da saúde conversou com
assistência começou a educação
agora nisso tudo vejo que a gente tem
desigualdade entre e incra fundamentais
uma complexidade interação gigantesca e
essas limitações estruturais da
fragmentação da sobreposição e do
isolamento cento setorial com uma
cultura lembra que a cultura diz
continuidade nós temos a compulsão pela
maternidade a paternidade dos programas
é que entra o governo cabo um programa
tão sem avaliar nada nesse contexto que
nós temos que fazer uma mudança em
direção a uma nova gestão desses dessas
conversas políticas
uma mudança que seja capaz na sua nova
gestão da sema matricial e intersetorial
mais do que isso a mudança que seja
efetivamente profissional tecnicamente
sólida orientada por metas com
capacidade ter compromissos com
resultados na realidade brasileira uma
gestão de qualidade orientado para
resultados é elemento fundamental para
combater a desigualdade não é uma agenda
neoliberal retrógrada conservadora ao
contrário é inspiração de uma mudança
que da alavancagem para uma mudança
sustentável no que se refere à igualdade
no entanto para além de uma gestão
profissionalizada que seja matricial e
que seja capaz e intersetorial eu
preciso dar conta de ter um espaço de
troca de diálogo forte com aqueles que
são os atores concretos dessas áreas
vulneráveis
eu preciso produzir uma escuta fortes
não assembléia esta não ficar elementos
mais uma escuta parte forte que seja
capaz de captar no território aquilo que
é pulsa enquanto com um vigor enquanto
necessidade de ter uma leitura crítica
sobre isso para a qualificação dessa
demanda e criar um espaço de
compartilhamento um espaço de troca de
interação em que a partir de uma escuta
forte atenta e crítica não paternalista
e uma
estão comprometidas com o resultado eu
seja capaz de produzir um campo de
encontros um campo de encontros que
tenha na sua uma força motriz uma visão
de compromisso com resultados e entrega
e com qualidade e eficiência daquilo que
a gente é capaz de fazer isso significa
evidentemente abrir espaço para o
contraditório uma gestão pública que
quer ser capaz de transformar e reduzir
a desigualdade tem que interagir com
contraditório ser capaz de se reformular
e propor caminhos que são caminhos
consistentes neste momento algumas
coisas e diz não mas aquilo que se diz
sim sede sem sobre o conteúdo sobre o
prazo e você entrega com a qualidade
naquele prazo que a gente tinha
comprometido para fazer isso eu tenho
que ter essa gestão matricial integrada
com uma participação comunitária ativa
capaz de ter aderência ao sujeito e aos
territórios e com uma visão em que a
efetividade dos resultados a entrega
daquilo que tudo pode ser transformado
vai ser assegurada no prazo comprometido
no prazo acordado nesse espaço público
que não há espaço estritamente
governamental um espaço público que tem
os governos legitimamente eleitos nas
três esferas tem a sociedade civil
organizada tem o setor privado tem a
sociedade civil que não está organizada
mas que pode ser ativa enquanto você
convoca e nesse espaço público você
produz efetivamente a república
a república em direção a um caminho que
pode concluir com isso uma enfrentar uma
frase do nelson rodrigues
o dramaturgo genial um equivocado em
termos das suas escolhas futebolísticas
mas não quis criar polêmica desculpe
está certo mas que queria dizer e dizer
que o subdesenvolvimento não se
improvisa subdesenvolvimento é uma obra
de séculos
o nosso desafio para pensar a metrópole
contemporânea é reconhecer que
desenvolvimento que vai associar
essa estratégia de redução de
desigualdade também não se improvisa de
forma alguma ele tem que ser
tecnicamente eficiente politicamente
ativo parametrizado resultados e com o
compromisso que sejam críveis e
entregáveis no entanto o desenvolvimento
não pode esperar por certos
ele tem que ser uma obra de hoje uma
obra que permita a partir da coordenação
das políticas públicas produzir
propósitos de justiça de equidade de
liberdade que viabilizem um rio
integrado um rio sustentável um rio
diverso
evidentemente um rio que diga que é
possível um outro arranjo metropolitano
no mundo contemporâneo
obrigado